>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Ev Small.
I'm here to welcome you on
behalf of the Washington Post
which is a charter sponsor of the
National Book Festival and also
on behalf of the Library
of Congress.
I'm a former editor at the
Washington Post and now working
at the Library of Congress.
So, I get two good places there.
Just a caveat, you may
have noticed the cameras.
The Library of Congress films these
talks for webcast on its website.
So, if any of you told your
families you were going off to work
for a few hours, please duck down
when the camera pans the crowd.
But we wanna make sure
you know that.
Right now we're gathered to hear
from Elizabeth Kostova whose
first novel, the eerie, hypnotic
and authentic The Historian is what
one reviewer called a toothsome
reworking of the Dracula
myth indeed.
It's worth pouring out for all
of you book lovers here today
that Kostova's undead Dracula
is a historian, an archivist
and a bibliophile of sorts, what
one reviewer calls a bibliomaniac
which probably describes
many of you as well.
A Dracula with a penchant for
librarians, what could be better?
[ Laughter ]
>> Kostova spent a good part of
10 years writing The Historian
but it immediately soared in to the
stratosphere becoming the fastest
selling hardback debut
novel in US history.
A record we think it still holds.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
[ Laughter]
>> We need look no farther
than right across the mall
from where we're sitting now
to the National Gallery of Art
for the momentum for her
current novel, The Swan Thieves,
where an attack on a
painting propels the story.
Don't anybody get any ideas.
Elizabeth Kostova has
worked in a number
of things including recording folk
music in Bulgaria and mowing loans
at least according to one source.
But we're lucky she
turned to writing.
In her work she conjures up
the powerful effects of myths,
the power of obsessions, and
the pleasure of old libraries.
One last thing I'll tell
you that you might not know.
Her interests in books and
libraries started early.
According to a reliable source, her
mother who was a librarian took her
and his sisters to the public
library and they were each allowed
to check out 30 books for which
they had a special shelf at home.
So please welcome book
lover, Elizabeth Kostova.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much.
Can everybody hear me well?
Good, okay and I'm already
knocking the mic off the stand
but I'll try not to do that again.
I know many of you are librarians
and I feel I should say something
about this before I say all
the usual formalities which is
that when my mother who was one
of my best readers in addition
to being a librarian read the
manuscript to of The Historian.
She said, you know, I love this
book and I'm just a little concerned
about the fate of all
these librarians.
So I was very careful to
dedicate my second book to her
which she has appreciated
and which we have shared.
I do love libraries and like all of
you I love books and I'm so thrilled
to see this outpouring of people
and readers today here on the mall.
And I also wanna say I'm so thrilled
to see all the reading programs.
I hope that you've all had
a chance to check those out.
The programs that help us
raised readers in this country.
That 30 books at the
library story is true
and I think it is a great gift
to children to be given books
and take them to the library.
So, I wanna say thank you very
much to the festival for having me.
I'm honored and I'm honored
that you're all here.
I'm gonna speak very briefly
because what I'd really
like to do is answer
your questions and talk
about the subjects you
would like to discuss.
So, I'll just tell you as you
heard my first book, The Historian,
took me 10 years to write.
The good news for those
of you who read it is
that my second book is The Swan
Thieves which came out in January is
about a 120 pages shorter.
So, I feel that-- it
also took me about four
and a half years to write.
So, I feel I'm getting
shorter and faster, I hope.
The inspirations for the two
books were very different.
The first one as you
know is about Dracula.
I have to say it.
It was a great surprise to me to
find myself writing a literary novel
with elements of the supernatural.
I'm always very surprise when
people say to me, you know this--
I don't usually, something I feel,
I don't usually read vampire books.
I don't either.
I never read vampire books
and then I'm always pleased
when they say I enjoyed
this one anyway.
So, I was fascinated by-- to
hear Isabel Allende's talk.
I hope some of you heard that.
Yes, and she's someone I admire very
much as a person as well as a writer
and I loved what she said
about how she lives other lives
by writing fiction.
And one of the things that's
been very entertaining to me
about having written a book
that's about experiences
with the mythical Dracula is
that people still ask me
whether this is an autobiography
and so, no it's not.
One of the joys about writing
a book about the impressionist
and as you heard some of the scenes
in The Swan Thieves are set right
here in the National Gallery
around some of the
fantastic paintings
in the 19th century galleries there.
But one of the great
things about writing a book
about the impressionist painters is
that nobody asks you ever whether
you believe in them or not.
So I would like to actually open
this up very early to questions
because I think I'll be
able to tell you more
and tell you exactly what
you like to know, I hope so.
So if you wouldn't mind coming
up to the mic 'cause I'm actually
a little bit hard of hearing
and I'll answer the question
you asked if you come
to the mic instead of
something I made up.
So that would be great.
Nobody has any-- okay.
[ Pause ]
>> Yes, and please the mic
>> Good morning, ma'am.
>> Good morning.
>> First of all, I very match
enjoyed both of your books.
I just like to say that upfront.
I noticed on your website
when I've last check it
that there's been someone hired
to write a screenplay
for The Historian.
And my experience has been
that really great books often
make really lousy movies.
And I was just wondering if
you could speak a little bit
to any concerns you might have had
or any influence that you have tried
to maintain on turning The
Historian into a movie, thank you.
>> Thank you.
Did everyone hear the question?
Well, it's about the movie that's
projected for The Historian.
Yes, of course when you write
a novel you feel concerned
about what might happen to
it when it becomes a movie
if you're lucky enough to
sell it for a movie deal.
And it did sell several years
ago, quite a few years ago now,
about four and half years ago
to Sony-Columbia Pictures.
And it's sold to a studio that
has made some wonderful movies,
Red Wagon Pictures, and I'm sure all
of you have seen some
of their movies.
They make some blockbusters
and they've also made
some really good movies
from books including novels.
Including Memoirs of a
Geisha on which they worked
for 7 years very closely with
the author Arthur Golden.
They have a track record of working
closely with authors which I liked.
But I think when you sell a book to
Hollywood in particular you do have
to kind of let go of
it because it's likely
to become a very different animal.
And I'm curious to see what they do
but in the end all I could
do is choose a studio
that seemed closest
to what I wanted.
I will tell you one
really quick thing
and then I'll take
the next question.
When I first went out
to meet with the studio,
they said, well I asked them.
I have one very frank question.
Do you intend to make a horror
movie out of this novel?
And they laughed and they said well,
we've heard how you
feel about horror.
That you're not a fan of the
hardcore genre, and we want you
to know that we intend
to make a movie
that will be terrifying
and beautiful.
And I thought that was such a
good answer for a novel like this
so that gives me a lot
of faith in the studio.
Yes, please.
>> The Historian, although I do
read a lot of supernatural fiction.
I like other types,
historical especially.
What I loved about that book was the
nested journals of how you did it
and how you straddled the 20th
century's history, cold war
and pre-cold war, and so for
me, Dracula kind of emerging
out of this made a
whole lot of sense.
But I'm curious, what made you pick
that, that framework for the novel,
those interacting journals
of interacting people?
>> The question was about the
structure of The Historian.
It is a series of documents.
In fact the whole book is a
document that's put together
by the main character.
And there are a lot of
journals and letters
and even an academic paper in it.
And I stole this shamelessly
from Victorian novelists.
They premiere the great novels
and the novelists I read the
most often although I read a lot
of contemporary fiction as well.
But I love that sense as
a re-- when I'm a reader,
of having been given a document,
especially letters and journals.
It also is a way to get
very close to characters.
I think there's a part of us and
probably not a very good part of us
that would love to read
other people's mail.
So even if we shouldn't and we
don't, it's there's a kind of joy
in being allowed that close to a
character so that was part of it.
The other reason I chose that format
was that it's what Bram Stoker used
for his brilliant novel Dracula.
And Dracula, I have no idea whether
Dracula's a great literature or not
but it's just one of the
best reads I've ever read.
And as you know, it's
completely told in documents
and you get an amazing sense of the
characters through that structure
so it really was because
of the Victorians.
Thank you.
Yes, ma'am.
>> My question is more of
a writer process question.
What is your writing process and
how did you maintain your stamina
over 10 years in such
a dense rich book?
You know to keep going, you
know, keep it organized,
keep remembering all the story
lines and the threads through it.
>> Thank you for that
question about writing process.
You know, I've had a very
different writing process
with each of my two books.
I'm now working on
a third and again,
it's quite different
from the first two.
When I wrote The Historian,
I did keep going for 10 years
and I was really fascinated to hear
what Diana said a few minutes ago
about writing her first book.
That rang very true for me as
well that she kept going partly
because she wanted
to prove to herself
that she can finish something and
that was incredibly important to me.
I had a feeling I might be
stuffing this into a drawer forever
but that I would know
I can finish something
and I wanted to be able to do that.
I also had three children under the
age of six like Diana and when I--
in fact I started it right before
they were born so it was even,
they're even younger than that
part of the time and frankly,
I think it was an escape.
I think that it was the part of
my day even when it was 20 minutes
of my day when I actually
was handling something
that didn't have egg on it.
So it was a great sort of personal
vacation including doing the
research and the research
took a long time.
That's one of the things that
make me a very slow writer.
The writing process, writing process
I think is fascinating to all of us
and when I wrote The Historian I--
because that book has a very
careful, logically plotted kind
of framework, about halfway
through, I outlined all of the rest
of the book and the original--
the first manuscript of it was
about 1100 pages, first typescript.
So I really would have
lost my way eventually
if I hadn't plotted it carefully
and worked on it in the order
in which you read it, pretty much.
I learned a long time later that
the best way, the most efficient way
to write a mystery is to write--
to know what the heart
of the mystery is.
In the case of detective
fiction that's the crime.
In the case of an historical novel
that might be a mystery from history
but to know that ahead of time
and then go back to the beginning
and work forward to that so
I think I must have written
in the least efficient way possible.
But it worked for me.
It's the order in which you read it.
Finally, though I had a sort of--
after I finished that
I had a revelation.
I went to-- I was visiting with a
friend who's a wonderful novelist
and short story writer and I asked
her what she'd been working on
and she said oh, I've been
working on my novel this morning
and I said, wow, that's lovely.
What chapter are you on?
And she said well, I don't
know and I was shocked by this.
I had no idea you were allowed
to write a book in that way
and so I've promised myself
that if I ever wrote another novel
I would try to write the way she did
which was to have the
archivist story, the characters,
and then to write whatever seemed
most compelling at that time,
whatever voice was most important,
whenever a scene occurred to you,
and then of course when
you do that, you have--
you end up with masses of material
which you have to stitch together.
This was the way I
wrote The Swan Thieves
which has a heavily psychological,
very intimate feel to it
and it was a great process
for that particular kind
of story because of that.
But of course, I just spent about
over a year putting it together
in the order in which you read
it which is now an interweaving
of the 20th and 19th centuries.
Can everyone hear me alright?
It feels like it's bouncing
in and out but maybe
that just makes it sort of, I
don't know, it gives it texture.
But if you start being able to not
hear me, please wave from the back.
Yes ma'am, thank you
for that question.
Yes.
>> Hi! It may interest you to learn
that your grandmother Eleanor
Stevens was my high school librarian
in Asheville, North Carolina
and helped to instill
in me a great respect for
books and love for reading.
So yes and--
>> Thank you so much
for telling me that.
>> You're welcome and my question is
I'm very intrigued by your interest
in myth and its import in our lives,
our understanding of
our own psyches.
One author who I think
exemplifies this in her writing
and whose books I love
very much is Sue Monk Kidd
and her book The Secret
Life of Bees.
I 'm just wondering if you could say
a little bit more about your love
for myth and your interest in myth.
Thank you.
>> Thank you so much and
thank for telling me that.
I'm thrilled.
My grandmother was a wonderful
encourager of reading and--
in her family as well
as in the library.
I'm so happy to hear that and she
read all of Jane Austen allowed
to me by the time I was 16.
So I can't think of a better
training for a writer.
So thank you.
I am very interested
in myth although I am
certainly no expert on it.
I imagine many of you
know much more about it.
I've never studied myth in a kind of
formal comprehensive way but I think
that it's fascinating that there are
stories that last for us and some
of them have lasted
for thousands of years
and they are still powerful for us.
Dracula has become
one of those although
over hundreds rather
than thousands of years.
In The Swan Thieves I heavily
used the myth of Leda and the Swan
which is a favorite subject of
painters of course through the ages.
But it's also I think
just one of the strangest,
most fascinating stories out
there, the story of a human being
and the divine or a human
being and the beast.
Do we know whether it's
beast or the divine?
It's really an amazing story
when you think about it.
I think it's very interesting
that if you look, for example,
at the movies that become-- that are
sort of box office, enormous hits
or television shows that have
millions of people glued to them.
At the heart of those, you
find exactly the elements
that we love in our myths.
I had the experience a few years ago
when my children were
quite a bit younger.
I'm reading aloud to them from
that wonderful book of Greek myths,
the D'Aulaires book which
probably some of you have
that has watercolor illustrations.
It's a classic children's work on
myth but a pretty sophisticated one.
And my children who were
pretty good but they
like most children may never
believe in bedtime or baths
so I guess that's normal but when we
were reading that book which is all
about things like Helen of Troy
and people chained to rocks
so their livers can be
eaten out by an eagle.
They would say every
night to one another.
Quick, get your pajamas
on, get your pajamas on.
We're going to have Greek myths
which I think is so remarkable.
There's just something deep in
us that responds to these stories
and they can be chosen only by time.
Thank you.
>> And piggybacks on
that a little bit.
Would you talk a little bit
about your time as a child
and your father telling you
the stories of Dracula and how
that all-- did it scare you, did
it you know, did that come back
to you as you were writing.
Would you talk a little
bit about that?
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
The question was about the stories
my father told me about Dracula
when I was a child and I feel
less than hesitant to say
that my father is a very nice man.
He is a wonderful storyteller
and from the time my sisters
and I were little he told
us a lot of great stories,
many of them from his imagination.
>> But some of them as in the
case of Dracula from things
like movies he had grown up with and
he grew up in Brooklyn and Queens
in the '30s, '40s,
early '50s and he went
to all those classic
Dracula movies, Bela Lugosi
and all those great,
great Dracula classics.
So his Dracula stories were heavily
based on those movies which in turn
of course are based on
the Bram Stoker book
and in them the noble Englishmen
always tracked Dracula to his lair
in his stories and it always worked
out very well for the good guys
and they always ended
in Dracula's castle.
He told us these stories while we
were traveling in Eastern Europe.
He was a-- he is a professor
and he was given a post
in Slovenia and then in Yugoslavia.
So the magical thing about
this for us as children was
that we often were hearing them
while we were actually having a
picnic at the foot of a 13th
century castle, for example.
So they were incredibly real
that gave me a sense that myth
and history and travel
were all kind of one--
could all become together
and be one thing in the mind.
So that is why I've dedicated
my first book to him.
Thank you for asking about that.
Yes ma'am.
>> Thanks.
The Historian introduces to so many
wonderful and exciting new places.
Where has been your
favorite place to travel?
>> The question is where is my
favorite place to travel then?
That's honestly very
hard for me to answer.
It's a -- I love thinking
about that.
Many of the places in The Historian
are places I know very well.
I lived there or I traveled there
long before I wrote the book.
A couple of them I
didn't get to until
after I've finished the manuscript
either for research or even
after the book was published.
So I had to do a tremendous
amount of research
to make sure I knew what those
places would have looked like,
smelled like, sounded like
at those particular periods
and it would be very hard for
me to choose but I have to say
that Bulgaria is extremely,
extremely close to my heart.
My husband is from Bulgaria and I've
been going there off and on for more
than 20 years and I have a kind of
second life there where I know a lot
of writers, publishers but also a
lot of people who have nothing to do
with the literally world and are
very interesting people living
in a way that is some ways extremely
different from what I grew up with
and those, Bulgaria was such an
inspiration to me for The Historian.
As you know it's-- it's-- if
you read the book about a third
of the novel is set in Bulgaria in
the 1950s and when I went back there
on book tour the book was touchingly
a huge success in Bulgaria
in Bulgarian translation and
when I went back there I met
so many wonderful writers
who were struggling,
struggling to have any opportunity.
It's hard to be a writer
anywhere but in Eastern Europe
after the collapse of communism,
there was just no funding
for the arts.
So a few years ago I
started a foundation
with the international
royalties from The Historian
to provide competitive
opportunities for writers
in Bulgaria, literary writers.
It also provides opportunities for
American writers to go to Bulgaria
and work with translators
and with Bulgarian writers
so I really urge you
to check it out.
It's become much bigger than
just my own project and if you
like to see the website for it.
If you're a writer and you
like to apply for example,
it's www.ekf for Elizabeth
Kostova Foundation dot edu.
Thank you for asking that.
[ Applause ]
>> Actually I think you
just answered my question.
I read The Historian as a
peace corp volunteer in Romania
on the Bulgarian border and I
was pretty surprised and please
that the spot on psyche and kind of
characters of the Eastern Europeans
in the book, so congratulations.
How did your interest in Eastern
Europe start since we've already,
you just explained
where you've been?
>> This-- that's amazing
that you did that, wonderful.
It must have been a great
experience, peace corp in Romania.
And I have been interested in
Eastern Europe since I was seven
because of my father's career
because he took us there
and we lived in Slovenia for about
six months so it was long enough
to really-- for us to
really get a feel for it.
And I've stayed interested ever
since really and so did my parents,
so it just seemed like a
natural place to set a novel
and I'm very pleased that it
seemed, with your experience there
which I'm sure was profound.
I'm very pleased that
you found it accurate
for what you know people
there, so thank you.
>> I also have a Bulgarian
directed question.
My father-in-law escaped Bulgarian--
communist Bulgaria and so my husband
and I were thrilled to see
so much Bulgaria in the novel
and also I can see my father-in-law
and his personality and quirks
in the novel which was really fun
and I guess my followup
question is how much of that part
of the world Romania-Bulgaria
inspired your story
and how much did you have to
include all your great descriptions
of the scenery because of
the material that you chose?
>> Thank you.
Your family sounds very
interesting and again,
I'm glad it seemed accurate to you.
I found that setting a book,
that writing a book about Dracula
of course makes Romania a
major topic and I really tried
to include scenery that seemed
to fit the story itself.
The places, to have the characters
go to real places and many
of those places you can go.
In fact I was sort of half
pleased, half horrified to hear
that there are historian tours
in both Bulgaria and Romania now.
I really recommend that you-- I
mean they may be very good tours
but I recommend you just take
your backpack and get on the train
and ignore them because
you'll see much,
probably much more off
the beaten path places.
But I did try not to simply hit
famous places in those two countries
but to really incorporate
the story and the scenery
and they are beautiful countries.
I mean, if any-- most
of you probably saw the
movie Cold Mountain.
That was field in the
Carpathians in Romania
which is why the mountains don't
look quite right but they--
it's gorgeous, they are
wonderful countries to visit.
Does that answer your question
or was there another part?
>> No the last three
has covered my question.
Thank you.
>> Alright.
Good. I just wanna tell
one really quick story.
When I was in graduate school I
was in a wonderful writing class
that included some graduate
students from other departments
at the University of Michigan.
And there was a young woman there
who announced on the first day
when we had self-introductions
that she was from Romania and I was
in the middle of writing
The Historian
and I'm feeling pretty shy about it.
I mean I wrote it in private,
mostly in private, for about--
for those 10 years and I went
over to her after class one day
and I said you know, I
was fascinated by the fact
that you said you're from
Romania and I just wanted--
I wondered if I could talk with you
because I'm writing a novel that's
partly about Romania and she looked
at me and she said
oh, that sounds great.
I sure hope it's not about Dracula.
So I'm afraid, you know, and
I have to add that she's one
of my best friends now and
she helped me enormously
with The Historian and ended
up really approving of the book
and helping me with the Romanian
dialect and Transylvanian customs
and is very knowledgeable.
But I think that Eastern Europe
of course has had its share
of stereotypes and
so I've also tried
to stay away from some of those.
Last question.
>> Vampires have been a
real pop culture phenomenon
in the last couple of years.
Did you know when you
started writing about vampires
that you would be part of this
whole plethora of books and movies
and TV shows about vampires?
>> You know when I
wrote The Historian,
I have to say it was a
little bit before that wave
that has included the Twilight
series and all but it was
after Anne Rice and as I said,
I'm not really, to be honest,
I'm not a reader of genre vampire
literature so I wasn't very familiar
with a lot of those
books but I did--
I have been astonished
since then by this wave of--
this parade of vampires
into popular culture.
I do think that this is nothing new.
I mean, vampires live
up to their reputation
by never ever dying even
if you want them to.
And I think it and this started
in about 1760 in literature
and it happens every 40,
50 years and I think again
in the mid 21st century when
everybody has forgotten this
and were on to something else,
vampires will come back and some
of us will be saying to
our grandchildren oh,
I think there was some kind
of vampire craze back
in about 2007 or 8.
>> So it's-- I think it's the
nature of vampires and again,
I think that speaks to the
power of myth in our lives
that we love this-- we love
and we love to hate this figure
of ourselves in the form of
the vampire, something human
but also evil, something
recognizable.
It's a lot scarier and a lot more
interesting than say the blob
or something that doesn't
seem as close to us.
I think we're fascinated by
that so for anybody who is
around in say 2065 or 70,
let's just keep an eye out
and see if they come back.
Thank you so much for all
your wonderful questions.
.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.